this morning we are remembering longtime  cbs news producer diane diane reneau who  died over the weekend after a 16-year  battle with pancreatic cancer renault  helped craft the stories you see right  here on cbs for more than 30 years  including 48 hours and sunday morning  and spent the last 20 years with the cbs  evening news in 2007 she talked about  her battle with cancer  i'm sick but i'm also i have  responsibilities i have a you know i  have a family i have work i can't just  you know i have to do those things and  as much as much as i was extremely  worried about being sick i also wanted  to  you know participate in the rest of my  life  just one of the best producers we've  ever had here at cbs news renault will  be deeply missed by our twin sons  colleagues described her as a superior  journalist who was the essence of  bravery